[Music]
glass can get boring but life never is
staying connected to friends from your
cellphone is normally easy except when
you're under the watchful eye of a
suspicious teacher make sure you watch
until the end to see why bicycle shorts
are a must-have if this is your first
time to our channel make sure to like
this video today we're talking about 10
ways you can sneak your phone into class
secret book every teacher's dream is to
see their students enjoy some personal
reading have you noticed that even when
a student is off the track they don't
get in that much trouble if it's because
they're reading you may not be allowed
to bring your phone into class but what
teacher would confiscate a book that's
why carving a perfect phone shaped hole
in your book is a genius way to hide
your phone and have your teachers think
you're just doing some extra credit
reading this way you can keep up to date
on what's trending and text your BFF
from the secret book that's too good to
put down hey guys please check out the
most awesome sisters on YouTube sister
fun watch can play the latest games go
on amazing adventures and just doing all
sorts of fun and silly things if you
have kids
little brothers or sisters or if you
just want to join in on the family fun
you subscribe to their Channel
ringtone your teacher can't hear
maybe you've managed to use a sneaky
technique to get your throne into class
without the teacher noticing but now
what we've all been in class when
someone's phone goes off and a guilty
hush falls over the whole class avoid
having your ringtone be your give away
with this sneaky tip while turning your
phone on silent is best it makes it too
easy to miss that must-see message and
vibrate can hit against the table or
something in your bag and be just as
obvious as a ring a third option is
downloading a frequency that the adult
eardrum is unable to detect you'll hear
the phone but your teachers will hear
total silence you can download ringtones
that are above 16 kilohertz to keep your
texting under the radar
short and sweet messages the worst thing
with text messages is that you can't get
them back once there since they will be
received and there's nothing you can do
about it
since you're hiding your phone in class
you don't get caught texting it's a bit
more complicated you might not get to
see your whole screen and then it can be
easy to accidentally send your text to
the wrong person next thing you know you
are writing twice the number of texts
trying to explain what went wrong and
before you know it your teacher is at
your desk asking for you to hand your
phone over you can just avoid this whole
mess by keeping your answers short and
to the point use shorthand to make your
words as small as possible so they are
fast and easy to type this will reduce
the chance of correction texts for your
type of your best bet is to send texts
that are only a few words and links and
leave the longer combos for the hallway
always keep your eyes up ever walked
into a room and everyone's head is bent
down in concentration it's a giveaway
that everyone's texting and it's not
just obvious for you it's obvious to
your teacher to look at your phone as
infrequently as possible by sending a
quick Texas when you're in between
topics in class when everyone is
shuffling through their papers you have
a quick window to type and see the types
but try and send one while your teacher
is in mid-sentence and you're bound to
get caught same with reading your text
keep your eyes on class material or the
teacher as much as possible don't forget
to keep your face neutral while you read
a hilarious text or else your teacher
will know something is up when they hear
a giggle from the back of the class when
you're supposed to be learning algebra
nothing funny about that
Thanks okay having your phone in your
bag makes it hard to access
in class and most teachers will stop you
if your bag is propped up on your desk
instead uses smaller objects like your
pencil case to conceal your device it's
much smaller so teachers will be less
suspicious that you're up to something
plus if you get the pencil case with
pockets and lie it sideways on your desk
so the zipper is facing you it's pretty
easy to open just wide enough to see
what that last notification is for add
another level of sneaky by taking
pencils and pins in and out of your
pencil case each time you text or use
your phone
this way you'll use your phone without
getting caught and get to add some
much-needed color to those class notes
you're taking food or sock one of the
best parts about how technology evolves
is how thin phones have become slim
bones make it easy to hide them in the
least obvious places making it easy to
sneak them into class some great places
are inside socks not only will this make
it easy to grab when you need but
teachers tend to look at your hands if
they sense a phone is around your socks
are the last places they're going to
check in the winter wear loose boots for
an easy spot to stash your phone what
better way to take advantage of the cold
than to use winter accessories as the
ideal hiding spots speaking of clothes
want to know why bicycle shorts are the
number one way to sneak your phone into
class keep watching to find out up your
sleeve just like a magician this next
tip just goes to show we have even more
ideas up our sleeve get cozy and wear a
sweater or long sleeve top to class for
a quick simple and effective way to keep
your phone hidden from your teachers
glance just slide your phone up into
your sleeve and pull it out when you
want to use it having something propped
up on your desk like a textbook will
make this method work even better stick
to rules about not staring at your
screen with frequent glances at your
teacher catch them looking your way slip
your phone back up your sleeve and no
one will guess you've been sneaking
peeks at snapchat calculator case math
class can get repetitive and boring when
you have the urge to text we have the
perfect solution with a sneaky way that
just seems like you came to class
prepared most scientific calculators
come with a protective sleeve to safely
store your calculator with a few simple
moves the calculator can be disassembled
to hide your phone within it it's pretty
impossible for anyone to see that your
calculator is really just a phone in
disguise
not such a DIY fan luckily you can
purchase calculator cases for your phone
place your phone upside
on your desk and the only thing your
teacher will see is a calculator while
you've managed to hide your phone in
plain sight in or behind a juice box
time to get crafty with this one most of
the time teachers are lenient with their
students drinking juice or water in
class got to stay hydrated get a juice
box wide enough and once in deep it will
make the perfect disguise for your phone
all you have to do is cut four diagonal
corners in the back of the introduced
box and fasten your phone inside not
only is this a clever disguise but it's
so convenient to use already placed
upright this trick makes using your
phone as easy as it is sneaky sneak a
fake last tip and lie it on its side so
your screen is facedown
bicycles short pocket disguised as
underwear this next trick is our number
one suggestion for both guys and ladies
it's impossible not to see how these
runner shorts or compression shorts are
the answer to all your worries when it
comes to sneaking your phone into class
these tight fit shorts double as boxers
or shorts to wear under your school
skirt make sure to buy a pair designed
for athletes with one to two pockets
engineered especially to hold an iPhone
not only will you feel comfortable in
this undergarment but it makes sneaking
your phone into class super easy what
links do you go to in order to keep your
phone on you at all times don't be shy
to tell us your secret in the comment
section down below and that's it for 10
ways you can sneak your phone into class
if you want to see more stories like
this make sure you watch 10
back-to-school DIYs for teenagers
[Music]